I have a ton of questions about Citadel
but I like throwing curved balls at the
beginning I did that with Joe and
Anthony as well um so I'm curious about
uh Butch and Sundance oh yeah so what's
the status of that we're in the early
stages of the creative process where you
know as you know we're working with rage
on page and um and Glenn Powell and both
of them have such stars in their own
right and bringing a lot to the table as
Coke
um collaborators and it's been a lot of
fun I'm really excited about that one I
think it's been great I'm looking
forward to it jumping into why I get to
talk to you guys yeah I like throwing
the beginning you know might as well ask
about you know so the series is six
episodes uh which of the six are you
most looking forward to audiences seeing
Oh that's a good question one in six
yeah me too me too one and six yeah
everyone said six so that's the reason
that's the reason I'm mad I don't have
four five and six because you know um
one of the things though about the
series is that every episode basically
ends on a cliffhanger so talk a little
bit about that aspect that you know
you're always you know what I mean yeah
yeah look it's a throwback to the great
serializations uh that people love so
much and so I think you know these are
very uh thrilling episodes you're sort
of you know riding by the the seat of
your pants every episode and so to end
on this delicious Cliffhanger that will
then Propel you to come back you know
week after week was certainly by Design
and in a story about spies and secret
identities and Duality and all that and
secrets
um there was real fertile ground I think
to craft some incredible uh Cliffhangers
yeah one of the things uh that I'm
actually very excited about is you have
another series that's going to be in
Italy another series that's going to be
in India I'm most excited about the
India one because I think RR is almost
primed a lot of people
um in the western audiences for Indian
content uh what can you tease about
those installments uh and how maybe
they're connected to this one well
they're extraordinary yeah um
extraordinarily different yes yes yeah
and we'd love to talk with you truly
when they come out because there's so
much we have to say about them but we're
such admirers of those creators we're
such fans of theirs and have been for a
very long time
um what we will say is you know Citadel
is a global spy organization so all of
the series sort of collide with Citadel
in in some way there may be some
characters that cross over
um you know some backstories we may
learn about certain characters or
Futures we may learn so we build this
big sort of Ip this big mythology with
those creators every other week we have
a global writer's room with them so
we're really holding hands as we write
this thing in real time together this
sort of tapestry of story and each of
them hold equal weight these aren't
spin-offs this first series Citadel is
an introduction and then Italy is the
next installment in India is the next
installment and all of them have the
same level of importance uh within uh
the larger mythology and world and all
of them them have the the same great
ambition when it comes to execution you
know as evidenced by the Fantastic
creatives that have been brought on to
spearhead them is there some sort of
plan one of the things I think that
there's a problem with uh with streaming
shows is that the first season comes out
in like January of whatever then there's
like a two-year break or even three
years before you get to the next season
so is there some sort of concerted
effort where like the next version in
Italy will be out the beginning of next
year like some sort of thing where it
there's always a version of Citadel at a
certain period of time we're certainly
cognizant of that uh and I think we as
viewers and lovers of TV have felt that
as well
um I think in the past few years you
know covid I think really derailed so
many series
um and and created that delay in many
ways but but we would love for the story
to feel like there's always a citadel
and you know a series to watch that
builds toward the larger mythology so
yes it's our ambition
um you know the best laid plans you know
can always go awry but but um we're
efforting to do that's really reward the
audience and to ensure that they
continue to come back and what you're
talking about is such an important part
of the experience when it comes to
elongated storytelling right because
it's a singular Journey that exists you
know between all of this series and so I
think that that amount of time that you
sort of have to wait to get into the
next chapter if you will is so important
for audiences in terms of maintaining
that investment and so it's a great
question because it's it's very top of
mind for all of us yeah obviously you're
gonna you know we're gonna see what
happens with the show and what audiences
think at the end of this month but uh
assuming it's a hit how quickly do you
think you could be in production on like
a season two good question I think you
know we always want to be as quick as
possible but it you know if we're so
lucky to have a second season we just
have to make sure the story is right you
know it all starts on the page uh for us
and as soon as we can lock that in and
we feel great about it and this is
exciting it's different and it evolves a
story uh then we go you know so
um well it would be a good problem to
have you know uh and we'll see we'll see
I'll just say have you started thinking
about it just in case always I mean I
think any time a story is created we
always think of the destination and
where it can go and what a second season
could be in part because we fall in love
with these characters in this world so
much that it's a thrill for us it's the
thing we dream about at night it's the
thing we we love just just thinking
about um so yes I guess is the answer
yeah I think as producers too we're
cognizant of the of the investment you
know uh and also as as fans you know we
are cognizant of our own investment in
series and and the the long-form
storytelling and so it's important to
reward people for that time and and
that's definitely the case here you
always want to think about where you're
going so that it's a it's fulfilling a
journey as possible one of the things
the first episode has a Massive Action
set piece that's like movie quality how
important was it to start the show off
with something like that what was there
because I've noticed a few series are
starting with a big action thing is it
to like to pull people in right from the
beginning it is it really is to pull
people in and I think to show them the
scope and scale of what Citadel is I
think uh this series introduces a
language that we often seen in terms of
the action that we often see you know on
screen in theaters with Bond or or
Mission Impossible I mean it's really
massive but so too I think that opening
train sequence was not only to sort of
forward the idea of what the action will
be but also tell the story of these two
spies of the romance the wit it it's
sort of like the symphonic piece that
tries to play every instrument and tell
an audience oh this is what you can
expect Citadel to be it has all these
ingredients I would imagine that's one
of a lot of creatives and they talk
about the making the first season of
anything is incredibly challenging
because you're learning about the
characters you're learning what works
what doesn't work just all the things to
pull off a show so what did you actually
learn making the first season that
you'll take with you if you get to make
a second season that's a great question
yeah
it's so interesting because I think this
experience is a little different than
one we've ever had before and perhaps
anybody since this is you know the first
truly Global franchise
um yeah I think ever right is that
typically those Lessons Learned come
from
our own choices right but in this
instance we learned a lot of things
because of the ideas coming in from
others because of where they were at in
their creative process and then those
ideas I think jolted us to say oh we can
you know we can sort of like turn this
knob here and like you know I think lean
in further there yeah and I think that
that was more than anything absolutely
the biggest lesson for us right I
totally agree yeah I totally agree I
mean it was very yeah it was like having
a continual writer's room so even in
post-production as our partners would
watch Siri you know our our episodes
they had ideas what if this what if that
and we love that I mean it was never
done
producing and creating season one is
never done it's just gonna air though
April 28th you know what I mean exactly
is the thing uh whenever you're ready to
send me four through six let me know
that note speed dating thank you so much